[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم يجتمع احمد سلماني المستشار
الاعلامي للرئاسه المصريه الثلاثاء في قصر
الرئاسه مع عدد من الشباب المشاق على
جماعه الاخوان المسلمين واشار مصدر رئاسي
الى ان اللقاء ياتي بناء على مبادره من
شباب استقالوا من الجماعه واستجابت لها
الرئاسه نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لنناقش في
محورين من يمثل شباب جماعه الاخوان
المنشقون عنها اما يشاركون في المظاهرات
في مختلف المدن
المصريه هل يعد اللقاء مع المنشقين على
الجماعه اعلانا بانتهاء محاوله التصل الى
تسويه سياسيه مع قيادات
الاخوان
فكر وارجع هذا هو عنوان المبادره التي
يعتزم ما يسمى بتحالف الشباب الاخوان
طرحها في اللقاء مع احمد المسلماني
المستشار الاعلامي للرئاسه المصريه وهدف
المبادره ودمج شباب الاخوان في المجتمع
كما يقول الناشطون في هذا التحالف الذي
يضم عددا من المنشقين عن الجماع ير ان
مصادر في الاخوان المسلمين اكدت ان شبابها
الحقيقي يقود الشارع لرفض الانقلاب
واللافت ان بدا الحوار في الرئاسه المصريه
مع المنشقين عن الجماعه يتزامن مع زياره
كاترين اشتون مسؤوله السياسه الخارجيه في
الاتحاد الاوروبي
لمصر اخوان المنشقون في قصر الاتحاديه من
اجل الحوار مع الرئاسه اللقاء مقرر عصر
الثلاثاء بين المستشار الاعلامي لرئاسه
الجمهوريه احمد المسلماني وما يعرف بتحالف
شباب الاخوان حتى قبل ان ينعقد اللقاء يلف
الحدث لغط كبير بشان حوار مع طرف مجهول
تاثيره على الارض وفي سياق سياسي شائك
ومعقد الطرف الذي ستتحول معه الرئاسه
المصريه الجديده هو مجموعه من الشباب
الذين انشقوا عن جماعه الاخوان علما ان
هناك اكثر من مجموعه وصفت بانها منشقه عن
الجماعه تداول اسمها الاعلام المصري وفق
مصدر مسؤول في الرئاسه الدعوه تقتصر على
مموعه واحده وهي تحالف شباب الاخوان ستعرض
وتناقش المجموعه مبادره باسم فكر وارجع
بالرجوع الى التصريحات الرسميه فهي تصر
على ان القياده الجديده في مصر لن تقصي
احدا من المشهد السياسي غير ان هذه
التصريحات لا تترجم الى افعال فالحوار
يفترض ان يكون اساسا مع الطرف الذي ازيح
عن السلطه بقوه العسكر معظم قيادات الصف
الاول والثاني لتنظيم جماعه الاخوان في
السجن وسلسله الاعتقالات مستمره ليس عناصر
الاخوان وفصائل في التيار الاسلامي وحدهم
من يشككون في جديه الحوار بين الطرفين
شخصيات سياسيه اخرى كانت قبل فتره قصيره
تقود محاولات للحوار لكنها اجهدت بفض
اعتصامي رابعه والنهضه كتب نائب رئيس
الجمهوريه السابق محمد البرادعي على حسابه
في تويتر بشان المسار السياسي الحالي هناك
حمله فاشيه ممنهجه من مصادر السياد
واعلام مستقل ضد الاصرار على اعلاء قيمه
الحياه الانسانيه وحتميه التوافق الوطني
البرادعي تحول مؤخرا الى خصم وهدف
لانتقادات سياسيه واعلاميه واجراءات
قانونيه يبدو ان اخرها اسقاط عضويه نقابه
المحامين عنه بارعه عدم ممارسه المحامه هل
الحوار والتوافق في مصر ممكن بلا ممثل
للرئيس المنتخب والمعتقل ومتظاهرين
المطالبين بعوده الشرعيه ما هو واضح ان
الحوار الذي قد ينهي الازمه في ام الدنيا
بعيد جدا في ظل سياسه تقصي بعض
ابنائها نناقش موضوع حلقتنا هذه مع ضيوفنا
هنا في الاستوديو احمد حسن الشرقاوي
المنسق العام لحركه صحفيون ضد الانقلاب
ومحمد عباس عضو المكتب التنفيذي لاتلاف
شباب الثوره السابق ومن لندن ينضم الينا
احمد عامر عضو تحالف دعم الشرعيه في
اوروبا مرحبا بضيوفنا استاذ احمد عامر
موقفكم انتم من هذا الحوار ما رايكم في
الجماعه التي ستلتقي بمؤسسه الرئاسه
ولماذا الان وفيفي اي سياق ياتي هذا
الحوار ياتي هذا الحوار يا سيدي الفاضل في
سياق فشل الانقلاب واستمرار فشل الانقلاب
ولان العالم واقول العالم باسره يرى شباب
الاخوان الذي يقف مع باقي الشباب المصري
من كل مكونات الشباب المصري في الشوارع في
الميادين في القرى في المدن يقفون جميعا
يرفعون شعار ربعه يرفعون صور الدكتور مرسي
يرفعون شعار الشرعيه في كل شوارع مصر
هؤلاء هم الشباب الذين يمثلون الاخوان
وليسوا هؤلاء صنيعه امن الدوله الذين اتى
به امن الدوله كما اتى بتمرد قبل ذلك
ليدعي امام اشتون ويدعي امام العالم انه
يتفاوض انا اجل واقدر الشيخ محمد الغزالي
عليه رحمه الله عندما اختلف مع الاخوان في
54 ثم ارادوا ان
يستخدمونه للطعن في ظهر الجماعه فرفض
الشيخ الغزالي يختلف ممكن اختلف مع
الجماعه او لا اختلف مع الجماعه لكن اقف
مع امن الدوله في ذبح الجماعه هذا لا يمكن
فانا اقول يا سيدي الفاضل وكن ليس كل منشق
عن جماعه الاخوان هم متعاملون متعاملون مع
الاجهزه او صنيعه الاجهزه هناك حركات
كحركه اخوان بلا عنف حركه احرار الاخوان
وغيرهم سيدي الفاضل انا اسعد جدا بهذا
بهذا النقاش بهذه الصوره يوجد من يختلف مع
الاخوان ويوجد من يستقيل من الاخوان ويوجد
من ينشق عن الاخوان ويوجد من يفصل عن
الاخوان ولكن هل هؤلاء يمثلون الاخوان
هؤلاء لا يستطيع ان يمثلوا الاخوان
الدكتور محمد حبيب وكان النائب الاول
للمرشد السابق للاخوان المسلمين لا يستطيع
الان ان يقف ويقول انا امثل الاخوان ولا
يستطيع ان ياتي بشريحه وتقول نحن من يمثل
الاخوان او شباب الاخوان يا سيدي الفاضل
هؤلاء يمثلوا انفسهم هؤلاء اقل من ان
يمثلوا ا واحد في المليون من الاخوان
المسلمين هذه الجماعه التي عمرها الان
تجاوز 80 سنه وبقيت من رغم محاولات كثيره
من امن الدوله لزعزع هذه الجماعه في 54
وفي 65 وفي 49 من قبل ذلك يا سيدي الفاضل
هؤلاء يحاولوا ان يسخروا من الشباب وهؤلاء
يحاولوا ان يضحكوا على الشارع المصري او
على بعض حكومات العالم ولكن هذا لا ينطلي
لا على منهم في خارج مصر ولا هم من في
داخل مصر محمد عباس عضو اتلاف الشباب
الثوره
السابق الحوار مع هذه المجموعات من الشباب
التي انشقت عن الاخوان هل تمثل الاخوان
كما ينفي ذلك ضيفنا من لندن هل لحوار مع
مثل هذه المجموعات اي تاثير اصلا على مجرى
الاحداث الان في مصر خاصه على المسار
السياسي خلينا بس نتكلم ان غالبيه هذه
المجموعات مجموعات اصلا انشقت عن جماعه
الاخوان المسلمين منذ فتره طويله لو
هنتكلم على عبد الجليل الشرنوبي هنتكلم
على دكتور كمال هلباوي مع احترمنا شيد ليه
مع نتكلم على ثروه الخرباوي وهو معروف
بعدائه الشديد لجماعه الاخوان المسلمين
وكتاباته المختلفه عن جماعه الاخوان
المسلمين الفتره
الماضيه هنتكلم على حركه اخوان بالعنف
المجهله المصدر التي لا نعلم من هم في
الاساس هنتكلم عن حركه احرار الاخوان ما
نعرفهم اصلا من من يدرس جماعه الاخوان
المسلمين جيدا ويدرس التنظيمات المغلقه
ذات الهرميه المعروفه يدرك جيدا ان هذه
التنظيمات تتكتل بشكل حقيقي في وضع
الازمات لا يمكن لهذه التنظيمات ان ينفرط
حتى وان كان هناك غضب حقيقي من القيادات
هذه القيادات الخاصه بها في في اوقات
سابقه ومن قرارات سابقه وان كانوا
بيراجعوا انفسهم في هذه القرارات هؤلاء
الشباب في قرارات القيادات الا انهم في
هذه الاوقات تحديدا لا لا تستطيع ان تفصل
الراس عن الجسد كما يقولون او تفصل هؤلاء
عن جماعه الاخوان المسلمين بالعكس في
اوقات الرخاء يحصل يحدث انشقاقات مختلفه
وفي الغالب تكون انشقاقات فكريه وتنظيميا
مختلفه تخرج بره هذا الامر لكن في اوقات
الازمات تاكد ان هذه المجموعات ستظل كتله
واحده ولن تخرج عن هذ وبالتالي من يمثل
هؤلاء لا يمثله شيء هو بالعكس هو ده
باختيار افراد معينين يعني انا عندي عندنا
مجموعات من شباب الاخوان مختلفه في الشارع
شباب الاخوان اللي بيقود فعلا دلوقتي بعد
اعتقال القيادات هم فعلا بيقود تحرك
الاخوان في الشارع تحرك الاخوان تحديدا
وهم جزء من تحرك المجتمع المصري في في
الفتره ديت ضد الانقلاب العسكري الحراك
الشعبي اللي موجود وعليه انت هو تم اختيار
الناس اللي هي موافقا على الانقلاب
العسكري نفس الصوره هو بيحاول يقسم ان انا
هعمل انفصاليه جديده ان انا هبروزها دول
اللي بيمثلوا الاخوان بالرغم ان هم لا
يمثلوا اي شيء داخل جماعه الاخوان
المسلمين حاليا لانهم لم يك لم يكونوا في
جماعه الاخوان المسلمين عند حدوث الازمه
في الاساس هي دي النقطه يجب ان ان نتحدث
عنها ا النقطه الثانيه هي نقطه استراتيجيه
جديده وضعها مصطفى حجازي منذ مجيئه ل
الرئاسه استراتيجيه ان ان ان نقوم بعمل
جماعه الاوان المسلمين جديده جماعه الاوان
المسلمين مستكين جميله نختار احنا قيادتها
اللي هي السلطه الحاليه تختار هذه
القيادات وراس حربتها ويتم الاتفاق ان هذه
القيادات القديمه تخرج من المشهد الناس
اللي موافقين على المشهد الجديد هم اللي
يفضلوا في الجماعه ديت والناس المختلفين
على المشهد الجديد هم اللي يخشوا السجون
ويتم التنكيل بيهم دي استراتيجيه فعلا
قالها وكتبها بورق ويعني الورق موجود عند
احد الناس اللي انا اعرفهم فيهم وشفته
بنفسي فالكلام ده موجود دلوقتي في ظل مثلا
زياره كاترين اشتون حاليا لمصر محاوله
يقول لك ان احنا بنفتح سبل لحوار مع
الاخوان المسلمين يعني التقت منك هذه
الفكره واسال هنا الاستاذ احمد حسن
الشرقاوي تحليلك انت للسياق السياسي الذي
يجري فيه الحوار بشكل عام السياق السياسي
سواء الداخلي او ما اشار اليه محمد عباس
لزياره كاترين اشتون عظيم هو هو له جانبين
في تقديري يعني الجانب جانب الشكله الجانب
المضمون من ناحيه الشكل طبعا انا متفق مع
الاراء السابقه في انه هو يعني تضخيم
اعلامي لمجموعه معروفه بانتمائها السابقه
حتى يتم تصدير هذه الفكره الى اطراف
خارجيه واطراف داخليه على انه هؤلاء هم من
سيمثلون جماعه الاخوان المسلمين اذا ينفي
عن نفسه تهمه الاقصاء اقصاء جماعه كبيره
بحجم جماعه الاخوان المسلمين عن عما يتم
يعني تدبيره في الوقت الحاضر اللي هم
بيقولوا عليها خطه خريطه المستقبل دي
القبيل وده مرتبط بالاساس نتنقل بقى من
ناحيه الشكل ناحيه التضخيم الاعلامي يعني
دي المنطقه اللي انا اقدر اتكلم فيها ان
هو زي ما عمل في الائتلافات بتاعه شباب
الثوره هو كسر ميدان التحرير ازاي ان هو
عمل السلطه الحاكمه اللي هي انا بسميها
الدوله المخابراتيه البوليسيه اللي اللي
ما بتختلف مع اي نظام هي اللي كانت موجوده
هي اللي عملت المزيد من الانشقاقات كتيره
جدا حركات وائتلافات وصلنا لعدد كبير جدا
من الائتلافات حتى تضعف التنظيم الاساسي
وال هو كان ائتلاف شباب الثور ضع القضيه
الام وضعت القضيه الام هنا ايضا نفس نفس
الاستراتيجيه نفس الخطه الامنيه اللي
بتتعمل انه اخلق كيان موازي وضخمه وصدره
للناس في الداخل وفي الخارج هنا بقى نرجع
لنقطه المضمون المضمون الثاني اللي داخل
فيه انه ده مرتبط يعني نفس يوم
اللقاء مع المسلماني ولل المصدفه يعني
المصادفه الغريبه اللي هي عليه علام استفم
كبيره كاترين اشتون انه المسلماني الذي
كان يكتب خطابات الرئيس المخلوع حسني
مبارك ايام ال 18 يوم هو ذاته الذي الان
هو الذي يلتقي بهؤلاء الناس في هذا
التوقيت بالذات يعني المساله واضحه
بالنسبه للي ايدهم في الملف على المشهد
المصري كاترين اشتون جت ثلاث مرات من بعد
37 من بعد الانقلاب العسكري واجراءاته جت
ثلاث مرات بمعدل زياره واحده كل شهر
الاتحاد الاوروبي هو الشريك التجاري
الاكبر لمصر وبالتالي اذا فرض الاتحاد
الاوروبي عقوبات على مصر فهي ستكون عقوبات
موجعه اكبر من اي دوله اخرى في العالم
ولكن يعني كان يمكن ان نقبل مثل هذا
التحليل لربما قد يقول البعض لو كانت
مؤسسه الرئاسه هي التي كانت وراء المبادره
لهذا الحوار مؤسسه الرئاسه تقول بان هؤلاء
هم اصحاب المبادره وبالتالي تناب بنفسها
عن كل تحليلات او تاويلات كهذه ما عنديش
يقين انه يعني انه الا اذا كان هؤلاء
الشباب لربما كما تقول كما اشر الذك ضيفنا
في لندن هم صنعه اجهزه كما يتهمون لاحظ
حضرتك انه يعني في بعض الاوقات اللي بيتم
فيها سحب الاجهزه الامنيه صلح الدوله
المخابراتيه النظام البوليسي المخابراتي
بيعمل ايه بيحط ناسه في مؤسسات وفي جماعات
وفي احزاب وفي ائتلافات ثوريه حتى
يستخدمهم عند الحاجه يعني يعني يوم ما
يبقى عنده مشكله مع الجزيره
تلاقي الناس بتوعه على طول قديموا
استقالات او خرجوا او عملوا موقف عندما
يكون عنده مشكله مع الاخوان المسلمين فسحب
ناسه حتى يحدثوا انشقاقا وهكذا هذا اسلوب
امني معروف معروف المشكله في انه كاترين
اشتون جاءت ارسال الزياره لها الان عندها
خطه واضحه عندها التزامات كشف عنها سعد
الدين ابراهيم النهارده النهارده سعد
الدين ابراهيم بيقول انه في المره اللي
فاتت احنا وقفنا هو ونجيب سويرس وده منشور
وموجود انه وقفوا قطه فرض عقوبات اوروبيه
عقوبات اقتصاديه اوروبيه على مصر مقابل ان
هم يعني هيضربوا قالوا لها ان ما عندنا
الشرطه مش متدربه ف عملت معاهم خطه لتدريب
150 ضابط مصر على اساليب فض الاعتصامات
والمظاهرات السلميه مع احترام حقوق
الانسان المره دي هتراجع وهتشوف عندها
بندين اثنين البند الا الاولاني مدى
التزامهم بحريات وحقوق الانسان وحقوق
المسجونين وخصوصا محمد مرسي ثانيا مدى
التزامهم بتوقيتات خريطه المستقبل طيب
سناخذ فاصل ولكن اريد ان اتحفظ هنا على
نقطه الزملاء الذين كانوا في الجزيره
واستقال لان ربما كل له ظروف خاصه حتى لا
يعني يح كلامك على انه قد مرر و وقبلت
بذلك نحن نتحفظ على هذا الكلام على كل حال
سناخذ فاصل قصير نواصل بعده نقاشنا نرجو
ان تبقوا معنا مشاهدينا
[موسيقى]
الكرام اهلا بكم من جديد مشاهدينا الكرام
في هذه الحلقه التي تناقش ابعاد اللقاء
المرتقب بين احمد سلماني المستشار
الاعلامي للرئاسه المصريه وعدد من الشباب
المنشقين عن جماعه الاخوان المسلمين مرحبا
بضيوفنا الكرام مره اخرى استاذ احمد عامر
من لندن
ا لعلكم تابعتم الكثير وانتقادات حتى من
داخل جماعه الاخوان المسلمين الاداء
السياسي
الذي ادته الجماعه وطبعا المرحله السابقه
والذي كان احد سبب انفجار الوضع في مصر
الا تفكرون في ربما مراجعه مواقفكم مراجعه
النهج الذي سرتم عليه مراجعه الكثير من
سياسات الجماعه حتى
ربما تفكر ايضا في الحوار مع السلطه
الجديده القائمه على فرض الامر الواقع
سيدي الفاضل
يوجد فرق بين شيئين الشيء الاول هو الذي
كان رقم اثنين في طرحك اننا كيف نتعامل مع
الانقلاب سيدي الفاضل الانقلاب الدموي
الفاشي الذي قتل ابناء الشعب المصري في
ربعه العدويه في النهضه في رمسيس في
المنصوره امام الحرس الجمهوري في
كل شوارع مصر في كل مكان لا حوار مع هذا
الانقلاب ولا حوار مع الدمويه بهذه الصوره
على الاطلاق يا سيدي الفاضل ما يمكن ان
تجلس انت ومن قتل ابناء الشارع ابناء
الشارع المصري بكل طوائفهم مسلمين
ومسيحيين لا يمكن ان تتحاور مع من حرق
المساجد ودمر الكنائس و يدمر الاقتصاد
المصري والشارع المصري ثم تقول لي هيا جلس
مع هؤلاء الانقلابيين هذا ما يمكن اما
المراجعات الاخوان جماعه عريقه جماعه
عمرها كما قلت اكثر من من 80 سنه هذه
الجماعه دائما تراجع نفسها هذه الجماعه
دائما تفكر والجماعه يوجد فيها من العلماء
والمفكرين والاطباء والمهندسين والطلاب
والعمال والفلاحين من يطرحه يا سيدي
الفاضل دائما تكون في انتخابات ودائما
تتغير القياده في داخل مكتب الارشاد وداخل
شورى الجماعه وداخل قيادات وقواعد الجماعه
هنا وهناك اذا دائما توجد مراجعات لكن هذه
المراجعات لا تصل الى ان تضع يدها في يد
من قتل الشعب المصري ممكن ان يجلسوا
يفكروا توجد اخطاء مما لا شك كل بني ادم
خطاء كما قال المصطفى صلى الله عليه واله
وصحبه وسلم يا سيدي عندما خرج النبي صلى
الله عليه وسلم يوم خرج بناء على طلب من
الشباب خط
التوابون
وخير خطئنا التوابون ولكن يا سيدي الفاضل
عندما خرج النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم وحدث
ما حدث يوم احد ما لام من صوتوا مع الخروج
ولكن لام من نزلوا من على الجبل هنا يا
سيدي الفاضل لابد ان نقول الجماعه تمضي في
طريقها محمد عباس لا اراك متفقا مع ما
يقول ضيفنا في لندن لا لا يا جماعه ما
بتعملش مراجعات خالص يعني جماعه لا تحدث
اي مراجعات للاسف الشديد منذ فتره طويله
بان هناك انتخابات هناك ت الاشخاص هنا في
مسار جماعه الاخوان المسلمين مسار يختلف ب
بين شخصيه واخرى حين تقول الجماعه عندما ل
نتحدث عن جماعه الاخوان المسلمين في
الفتره الماضيه اتحدث عن جماعه الاخوان
المسلمين منذ انتخابات المرشد الجديد
الدكتور محمد
بديع منذ بدايه هذه الفتره حتى الان هناك
معروف جيدا ان هناك موازين قوه داخل جماعه
الاخوان المسلمين كان يتحكم بها بشكل
اساسي البشمهندس خياره الشاطر تحديدا
ومجموعته ودكتور محمود عزت لا توج يوجد
مراجعات حقيقيه حتى الان عندنا ازمه
حقيقيه ط على اي مستوى على اي مستوى يفترض
ان تقوم الجماعه بالمراجعه لا حتى نكون
واضحين
حت ه انا بس في الوقت دوت وقت ان يكون
الناس تسجن في السجون و وتقتل
وتعذب صعب جدا ان نتحدث عن مراجعات في هذه
اللحظه المراجعات تقوم في اوقات الحريات
ثلاث نقاط اه يعني لا انا اتكلم
عن مراجعات سياسيه يجب عليها ان تراجع هذ
هذه الامور يجب عليها ان تراجع الفصل بين
بين الدعوي والسياسي بشكل اساسي يجب عليها
ان تراجع ادارتها للدوله وعدم تعاونها مع
الاتجاهات السياسيه المختلفه في اداره
الدوله في الفتره الماضيه هذا كلام نتحدث
فيه
بعد الكلام اللي نتكلم عليه اسمحلي انا
احشن برض
برض لا يجوز لا الجماعه ع الجماعه اسمحلي
م الجماعه انها ارت ان تخ البلد بينما
الاخرون حينما الان اقصو الجماعه وزجوا
بقيادتها في سجون واعتقلوا ما اعتقلوا
يكاد الان يتبعون سياسه استئصال الجماعه
من المجتمع بشكل انا متفق تماما مع عشان
كده انا قلت لا يجوز ان نتحدث عن مراجعه
فكريه او مراجعه لاخطاء في ظل ما هم جوه
السجون ويتم الاخصاء معاهم بالشكل دوت
بالعكس تماما انا وجدت التعامل بعض
الاتجاهات السياسيه بعض الاتجاهات
الليبراليه تحديدا اكثر فاشيه واكثر هيمنه
واكثر
تحكما في الدوله من جماعه الاخوان
المسلمين وده حقيقه يعني لكن في الاخير
انا عندما اتحدث هنا كان كان استهجان ان
هناك بعض المراجعات يعني انا اتذكر منذ
ثوره 25 يناير كم المواقف التي طلبنا فيها
جماعه الاخوان المسلمين حتى الانقلاب
العسكري لمراجعه مواقفها المختلفه ولكنها
لم تستجيب ولكن الان في هذه اللحظه التي
نمر بها ومصر تمر بها لا نستطيع ان ان
نقول لفصيل ما داخل مصر فصيل الوطني داخل
مصر مهما اختلفنا معاه في السياسه راجع
نفسك دلوقتي وانت تحت تهديد السلاح ا اعمل
اللي احنا عايزينه دوت تحت تهديد السلاح
وتحت تهديد السجون والمعتقلات لا يجوز باي
منطق طيب احمد حسن الشرقاوي هذه انشقاقات
عن الجماعات التي يعلن عنها بين حين واخر
الى اي حد تؤثر فعلا وبشكل حقيقي على
الجماعه على قوه الجماعه على حضور الجماعه
والله من دراسه يعني تاريخ جماعه الاخوان
المسلمين ممتد الاكثر من 8 عقود يعني
استطيع ان اقول انه الجماعه حدث عليها
انشقاقات كثيره للغايه لكن كل الانشقاقات
التي مرت بها الجماعه منذ تاسيسها وحتى
الان لم تفت في عدد الجماعه اي لم تؤثر
على مسارها او على خطتها او على تطورها او
على نموها وعلى حجم مشاركتها انما كانت
الانشقاقات تظل انشقاقات وتظل الجماعه
تسير في مسارها بتنظيمها بمنهجها بايدي
لوجها هل هذه الشقاقات كانت تاخذها
الجماعه بعين الاعتبار وتراجع نفسها كما
يقول محمد عباس طبعا وانا عايز اقول
لحضرتك انه في فتره جمال عبد الناصر ما
عمل انشقاقات على جماعه الاخوان المسلمين
هو كان في ذات الوقت كان
الدكتور كان وزير الاوقاف كان من جماعه
الاخوان المسلمين وغيره من منذ بدايه
الثوره هو حاول دائما السلطه الدوله
البوليسيه المخابراتيه تحاول ان تشق
الجماعات المناويه لها سواء كانت احزاب
شفنا الممارسات دي بتحصل مثلا مع الاحزاب
الكرتونيه اللي كانت موجوده رغم انها كانت
كرتونيه في النظام الحزبي ايام المخلوع
مبارك كانوا دايما يعملوا انشقاقات يجيبوا
ناس تطلع ويقولوا هو دول اللي بيمثل الحزب
وده ما بيمثلو اخرى بالتاكيد نظام مبارك
الانقلاب العسكري يريد اعاده نظام مبارك
كاملا ويمكن ده اللي بيفسر لنا ما ار على
المشهد السياسي المصري الان ان هناك يعني
حضرتك لو اما
تشوف رئيس الاركان السابق والجدل اللي
حوالين ترشيحه ومذكراته اللي بتنزل فريق
سامي عنان والرد من الطرف الاخر وال يعني
المشهد المصري مليان وفي احداث كتيره جدا
خلال الفتره اللي جايه ولكن تقديري انا
كمراقب وك كمحلل انه هناك انشقاقات في
جماعه مش في جماعه الاخوان المسلمين
الانشقاقات في جماعه الانقلاب جماعه
الانقلاب هي التي تهترئ و وتتفتت ولانها
مجموعه غير متجانسه اما جماعه الاخوان
المسلمين الانشقاقات لا تحدث فيها اثرا
لماذا لانها اكثر تجانسا حتى ان اتفقنا
ولفنا مع سهت تهترئ الجماعه ويظل الجيش
ماسكا بزمام الامور على كل حال وهو هو هو
العصب في هذه الحركه استاذ احمد عامر
الجماعه انشطتها الان بالقضاء محظوره ما
هو الحل
برايكم سيدي الفاضل كان هذا المسمى موجود
في وقت عبد الناصر في بدايه وقت السادات
في بدا في وقت مبارك بالكامل وكانت
الجماعه هي الموجوده على الارض في داخل
الاتحاد الطلابيه الاتحادات الطلابيه في
داخل النقابات في داخل العمال والفلاحين
في مصر هذه الجماعه كانت تسمى هذا المسمى
من قبل النظام السابق وكانت تخو الانتخ
وتسب الخات طيب حتى نربح الوقت الان ما هو
تصور خروج هذه الازمه
الان في دقيقه او اقل الخروج من هذه
الازمه يا سيدي الفاضل الخروج من هذه
الازمه يا سيدي الفاضل بلا بد ان يواصل
الشعب المصري طريقه وكل الشعب المصري ليس
الاخوان فقط في اقصاء هذا الانقلاب
والانتصار للشرعيه وعوده الشرعيه من جديد
وهذا سيتم الانقلاب فشل والشرعيه راجعه
والشعب المصري سيقول كلمته باذن الله
والنصر لهذا الشعب قريبا جدا باذن الله
تعالى شكرا لك احمد عامر عضو تحالف دعم
الشرعيه في اوروبا من لندن و نشكر ضيوفنا
ضيفين هنا في الاستديو محمد عباس عضو
ائتلاف شباب الثوره السابق واحمد حسن
شرقاوي المنسق العام لحركه صحفيون ضد
الانقلاب شكرا ضيفنا الكرام بهذا تنتهي
هذه الحلقه من برنامج م الخبر نلتقي باذن
الله في حلقه اخرى شكرا لكم والسلام عليكم
ورحمه الله وبركاته
[موسيقى]
ا